[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jermaine o'neal a former nba player
six-time nba all-star
he is the executive producer at least
one of the executive producers of the
new netflix documentary untold malice at
the palace the first film in the untold
series and the next film untold deal
with the devil chronicling the pioneer
boxer
christy martin that'll air november 17th
jermaine o'neill joining us on the
program jermaine great to see you again
what did you unearth that you didn't
know about the malice at the palace
well first of all dan it's great to see
you as well um
you know a lot of you know about this
document was it was information and and
and having a conversation and that was
big for me you know
it went about 10 years um after the
brawl happened and we had to go through
incredible amount of legal
incredible amount of you know civil you
know lawsuits and we we couldn't talk
much about it and honestly i didn't
really want to talk much about it um
to be completely honest and then this
thing just kept being an anniversary you
know and it's like anniversary
anniversary
and i knew that it was information out
there that was never talked about uh and
it was one of those things where i
finally just you know took some time out
to to interview some directors uh some
producers
um to kind of talk about you know
you know could we put together a doc
that one didn't alienate uh a league
that i care so much about
or you know the pacers or anybody else
um that i care a lot about uh but really
just to have the conversation for the
first time so people can get a different
perspective and see just how
uh the narrative was changed um and i
thought you know uh
this doc told everything
the when you hear from the fans who were
involved in this
did you interview any of those fans
no
no so one of the things i wanted to do
on this doc um and i have to say you
know
thank you to netflix for you know for
seeing the vision understanding division
the way brothers uh floyd russ who's the
director did a phenomenal job on
capturing it
um
you know my my job was to have the
conversation to get people
that were there uh to talk you know to
come on and i told them you know talk
candidly the fans himself never had any
contact with him uh hell to be honest
dan um when we shot this doc i never
even sold stephen jackson over on our
test we shot it all in different
locations or ben wallace or reggie
miller uh we shot it separately uh guys
wanted to speak openly about it uh
mainly because we want to put this thing
to bed so people can stop having
anniversaries and talking about it
anybody not want to be a part of it
well everybody wanted to be a part of it
i gotta say shout out to rasheed wallace
uh and and larry brown who actually
didn't did not make the final cut um
because we only had an hour and eight
minutes to put you know put all this
information in there so we're going to
lose some sort of information but
everybody wanted to be a part of it um
because i think everybody understood it
you have to understand too dan is that
when you're going through a process like
that uh 17 years ago and it seems like
it's been you know two lifetimes ago but
people still talking about it
you know it's a lot of it's a lot of
things out there right there's no real
template to how you deal with you know
player fan involvement right and and you
know from a perspective of a business
where the nba you know it is a real
business and multi-billion dollar
business
um you know
you have to react um
and they reacted um and
and to a point rightfully so but i just
didn't over a period of time once things
start to calm down
it was opportunities to talk more about
you know some of the detailed stuff that
actually happened and actually show
you know what you know what in the world
was going on in that arena that night
but did you feel like there was
something
bad going to happen before something bad
happened that night
no then
i mean
obviously we've had you know we've had
you know it was a rivalry between us and
and and the pistons uh it was always
intense but then you have to understand
like you expect to go into tough
environments that's what makes pro
sports what it is it's a great
relationship between fans and players
and you go into opposing arenas and and
the two teams that are playing are are
projected to represent that conference
uh possibly in nba finals uh it's no
there's no love in the environment but i
never thought at any point that i would
be wearing jersey and all of a sudden uh
you know offended from you know
offending for my well-being
what's that feeling like though when you
realize there's a fan right in front of
you
and he
and he wants a piece of you
do you do you even think can i defend my
am i allowed to defend myself even
though he's on the basketball court with
you
well i can tell you this i can tell you
this then i mean
you know you you go through a process of
just trying to
you know
go from understanding you go from you
know excited about you know beating the
defending champions uh we feeling good
about ourselves
um and going to a point where hey what's
you know looking at what's going on and
then you go you go to a point of
survival mode right people are now
starting to touch you people are now
starting to spit on you people are now
starting to hit you with things and all
of a sudden it is a court full of people
on the very surface that we we should
have been protected on and um you know
you know i've had this you know
conversation a ton over the last two
weeks about leadership
right leadership is is a word that you
hear a lot in sports and life and
leadership is typically in the workplace
right or maybe even at home but you
don't hear very much you know
conversation about leadership uh when it
comes down to protecting yourself and
others in a situation um that is
compromising
right and that's the thing that people
have to understand you know my position
with it is i'm gonna have to protect
myself and others in a situation where
we don't have anybody in the building
trying to protect us and there was
limited security there that night and
you know that added to this i'm what was
it like in the locker room when
everybody got off the floor
it was intense um
it was a lot of yelling and screaming i
remember just walking in um the locker
room and it was like a
movie set right because you had guys
that had torn jerseys you had guys that
had were bleeding from you know things
been hit or scratches you had you know
guys with like popcorn debris and all
kind of stuff all over them
and people were just kind of out of it
um
and it just it just went from like one
thing to another thing to another thing
because then you know once we actually
finally got settled in the locker room
the police came in and was trying to
take me to jail
and then you know and then i had a
situation with ron at the time when he
asked you know did he you know you think
we're gonna wait wait so what did the
police say to you prior to them wanting
to take you to jail
and listen
i i was i was sitting there thinking how
in the world you go through all of that
stuff out there
and all the legal stuff that was going
on out there and you walk in in in the
locker room the player's locker room and
you come directly to me saying hey you
coming with us right it was it was it
wasn't a ton of conversation
right it was like hey you know jermaine
you're coming with us and i and at that
point
um i was already mentally out of it
emotionally out of it and i just i
reacted and said what i said to them and
and i guess you know thankfully um they
respected that they understood where i
was coming from were they trying to cuff
you
they never got to that point but they
they understood where i was and i think
that was one of the benefits of being
six foot 11 260 you know where you know
you go into a situation and you see that
it's out of control and people are
emotional right and i was very emotional
at that time because i think it's
important for people to understand i
inherit inherited that jack inherited
that
right um jack doesn't jack goes in the
stands to to help ron and then the guy
throws the beer in this this stephen
jackson stephen jackson yeah right you
know i'm in a situation where i'm on the
floor but i'm on the floor
with other fans
that by the way is is hitting you know
hitting me you know and grabbing me i
was telling the story uh you know you
know in a couple of interviews
like people realize like i had just got
somebody off being around arm around my
neck and everything
right and so
i'll go from that to having to go to the
slot punch and then from a perspective
too then
you have to understand i slipped
the thing actually you got to ask
yourself what did i slip on people were
throwing things beers and everything
from the stands it was like it was like
a movie right and so
um
i'm gonna be completely honest this this
doc um it took about 10 years to do
um and i was fortunate enough to get
with the director and and netflix who
who who um were able to tell the
incredible story is it is for it's for
conversation and closure that is all
this doc is for and for people to
understand that all of a sudden you know
you go from a narrative of the criminal
and all this other stuff which is
bananas for me to even think about it
and i want to bring that up because that
word thug
any any time this was being described
you guys were thugs
what was it like to hear that
no matter if it was the evening news or
sportscenter uh you're being called a
thug
it was it was disappointing
um
it angered me
um
it ate away from me for a long time
i mean for a situation like that for
people to quit the judgment um not even
doing their job to do to wait and say
let me get my information right you know
and and and say what this is it was like
oh opportunity
here's an opportunity for me to to take
jabs you know at players
and the thing that hurt me the most not
even about myself
my league
was under attack right my peers that
wasn't even in that building was under
attack so
um i was really i was really really
disappointed um and i probably you know
over over time dan
um
it was like a virus like it just ate
away from me and because people realized
we couldn't speak because we had so many
pending i had eight laws i eat lawsuits
against myself
right and then all the criminal stuff
that that literally went on
for 10 years so you were sued by fans
sue by fans um
the guy that even tried to choke me
uh sued me uh sued by fans that you know
were you know people that were saying
they were emotionally
um damaged and it was just
it was ridiculous and and won everything
i want everything
um you know you know i i got to clarify
this because when you know i've spoken
about the lawsuit against
the nba and again there's no jab against
be i'm i'm forever alumni forever
grateful because it is awarded me so
many opportunities
but i think it's important when people
look at that whole situation when i go
through the appeals process
and and and the judge is allowed to see
every angle and see what act would
actually happen and say okay well you
know jermaine you had the right to do
what you did
that's important
right that is important to me because
the character session assassination was
a real thing dan
and honestly i felt it
it was never really the same and part of
my love you know when you're going
through a process like that
i love basketball right and part of that
was damaged and i knew that it wasn't
going to ever be repairable because
um people didn't understand it and
understand the real the real
narrative of the story
talking to jermaine o'neal the uh
documentary on netflix is uh untold
malice at the palace it's available now
why did you and ron artest have a
falling out
um
honestly um
as as a brother as a teammate
because it is an incredible brotherhood
in those locker rooms um
i did not understand
uh back then you know
people nobody understood mental health
right we wasn't educated enough mental
health is in your face in today's era of
sports and life
back then if you're if you're if you're
talking about your health you're talking
crazy and you know nobody wants to be
you know you know involved in that
conversation and
his reaction to stuff which i thought he
did a phenomenal job in the dock on
explaining
you know kind of how he approached it
and and honestly dan when i saw when
when netflix sent me the the first uh
cut of the dock
that was literally the first time i ever
heard him speak about his process to how
he deals with pressure how he deals with
everything and so it all started to make
sense and i felt emotional but back then
it was aggressive because i i was about
trying to win the championship
um he would just disappear he didn't
react well to you know to certain things
and
and i just didn't i didn't understand it
so we didn't have a very good
relationship
but you're good now we are good we are
good now um you know we
um you know we've had our first sit down
lunch together it was about two years
ago we talked often on text um
you know shout out to ron you know on
being able to talk openly about
his struggles
you were uh
what the 1996 draft
yep so you had you had kobe iverson ray
ray marbury
steve nash
and and and you're what
18 years of age at the time coming in to
the portland trail
17 17.
oh my god
that's pretty good draft did you feel
like
you know what am i i'm 17 should i be in
the nba
back then dan it was it was incredible
pressure because now you can you can
actually make yourself eligible for the
draft and then you know go through your
process and go back
back then if you made yourself eligible
as a high school player
you basically forfeited your college
eligibility so
i was nervous i was nervous um i have to
say you know big shout out to arantellum
is my agent my entire career uh son of a
carol um who walked uh me and my mother
through the process of understanding
what it was now i will tell you when i
made myself eligible
every week after that point it was
somebody else to claim for the draft and
i was like well
damn i am my mama get drafted and so i
was i was extremely nervous
[Laughter]
i mean it was some names coming out of
there that i was actually fans of like i
watched on television so it was like
man this may be a tough one were you
compared to kobe
for a little while of you know the
success of the high school player
in high school or no when you guys got
to the nba because kobe didn't play much
hit that first year but i didn't know if
like they were comparing the high school
player to the high school player and you
know who's having more success or did
you feel that there was competition with
you
it was it was definitely a lot of
comparisons you know for our success um
you know i was i came from a smaller
market
uh so not a ton of people knew about me
uh code was was kind of in that
direction you know for his last two
years of high school a lot of
conversation by him going going pro
but the success of garnett
kg was really set the standard right and
so if you didn't meet that level
of you know expectations as a high
school player then all of a sudden this
is criticism and i had to go through my
college one-on-one
for four years with portland and that
was the hardest
four years of my life uh larry bird i
think was in the front office with the
pacers when you were there you got a
larry bird story
no not really larry was was really he's
really quiet um he didn't come to
practice and take on everybody's
shooting
no no he he came to practice for sure he
just kind of sit down you know he's he's
really
direct and about his business um very
quiet um except for when he's playing
yeah you know you know it's something
it's people like that though right they
on the court and it's like they're a
different person and then when they step
away from the court who was like that
who who surprised you when they got on
the court and you're going damn man he's
up um
believe it or not people may laugh when
i say this
but
if you look at rasheed wallace
right when you look at the technicals
you look at the
screaming and yelling
and as soon as you see him put on the
street clothes
super calm
always laughing you know
people think that he's crazy right
because he you know he's leading the
league and texts every year and he's
screaming and yelling but as soon as he
walked off the court he's he's pretty
pretty mellow could you smell pot on his
breath during a game though at any point
[Laughter]
[Music]
i i remember being at a pistons game and
i nice rasheed passed me in the hall
and he was going out to shoot around
and it felt like it was a bob marley
concert that was uh following him
listen
savannah i'm gonna take i'm gonna take
you out for a drink we'll have that
uh when i come to dallas then uh we'll
go out we'll uh we'll have a beverage
well good luck with this i'm glad that
you're able to um have some closure with
this uh you went through a lot you know
lost a lot of money uh you guys lost an
opportunity i think to win a
championship that year and um you know a
lot to go through
thank you jermaine it's great to talk to
you again
thanks for having me dan uh jermaine
o'neill he was a six-time nba all-star
picked uh 17th overall by the blazers
and uh he's one of the executive
producers of the netflix documentary and
told malice at the palace